so it's all here then every
sweet-smelling speck of it
as for my compensation
strange form of payment why this is not
cash everyone has a hobby some men
collect stamps
I collected relics this thing is called
a fashions a ceremonial acts carried by
the bodyguard of emperor Nero for much
of term fascism derived no a form of
rule which in my opinion is getting a
bit of a bad rap lately
you know I had this under control
my wife's faster speed isn't everything
mr. thong you should have learned that
lesson by now hey youtubers it's Charlie
this is gonna be my legends of tomorrow
episode 5 video Miami Vice
Top Gun reverse-flash can't go wrong
Legion to do so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet this is probably my favorite episode
so far but you know mostly because they
had so much fun with that 80's genre and
I just think it's so hilarious you can't
really do episodes like this all the
time
I think it's been to their great benefit
that they've jumped around time like you
don't get stuck in any one particular
time for too long but they had so much
fun making fun of the 80s in this
episode that I'm gonna focus mostly on
the comic book stuff like the big
reverse-flash plan the Legion of Doom
formation then I'll talk a little bit
more about the funny stuff so just going
down the list reverse-flash Miami Vice
entrance my way is faster there in Miami
doing a Miami Vice riff so you have
Crockett and Tubbs in damian darhk--
references the nuke bomb
you hired me 45 years ago to blow up New
York City so we know they've already
been working together but not in an
official capacity they haven't actually
formed the Legion of Doom there is no
team up till the end of the episode when
damian darhk-- like finally comes to the
realization that he needs to start
manipulating time in order to change his
destiny the only thing in the episode
that I felt like didn't come across was
damien darhk's arc like he is such a non
reactor like he's so chagrined at
everything that it's hard to tell what
he's feeling at any given moment so I
feel like you know at the end of the
episode when he was like I need to
change my destiny take me with you it
didn't come across the way it was meant
to but he's meant to be afraid like
Sara's speech to him when she's like
these are all the terrible things that
are gonna happen to you there's nothing
you can do about it that's meant to
shake him but you don't really see it on
his face just because of the way Neal
McDonough plays him it's like trying to
get Darkseid to cry Darkseid does have
emotions like real people do he just
never shows them so if it wasn't clear
the stuff that Sara told him at the end
of the episode was meant to make him
afraid but the whole reason for
the episode is basically to heat up the
Cold War basically get Russia in the
United States or the Soviet Union in the
United States to attack each other it
was still the Soviet Union at that time
so they were getting ready to disarm the
plan was to blow up the summit so that
both leaders were killed and both
nations retaliated against each other
but on the side damian darhk-- liked the
thing that he was trying to get they did
a very pulp fiction thing where they
don't actually show you the talisman
they just opened the little box
he was the thing the reverse-flash
initially stole off of Rex Tyler that
talisman that was what they were trying
to get so here's the next big thing this
is a really comic boogie thing because
it gets back to comic book flashpoint
the reverse flashes single goal in his
life is to erase Barry Allen without
erasing himself that is why he cannot
chop Barry Allen's head off because he
would cease to be it would completely
destroy his timeline so he has to find a
way to get rid of Barry Allen without
getting rid of himself and that is what
his main goal is on legends of tomorrow
it's the whole reason for forming the
Legion of Doom so just keep that in the
back of your mind they just ordered four
more episodes so there's 17 episodes
total so you know whatever the
fulfillment of the reverse flashes plan
is we won't find out - like the last
couple of episodes of the season whether
or not he's successful but whatever it
is he's trying to construct that you
know like the special objects the
magical artifacts that he's using to
construct some crazy device to get rid
of Barry will probably learn what that
is pretty soon but just remember that
they kind of alternate between mythology
episodes where you have Legion of Doom
plotting like this episode was a big
mythology episode because it moved the
plot forward then they alternate with
like the one-off episodes where they
just go off and have an adventure that
has absolutely nothing to do with the
Legion of Doom so within the next couple
of episodes will probably start learning
more about what the reverse-flash has
planned for Barry Allen but we did get
that future message from Barry saying
that a war was coming like a big time
war it sounds like it's gonna get super
crazy
so we'll probably see some stuff from
that in the next couple of episodes
remember they jump around time so
eventually we'll probably travel to the
future and meet that old Barry Allen and
at the end of the Epis
most of you probably remember the end of
flash season 1 the reverse flashed the
Harrison wells reverse flash built a
Timeship that was modeled after an old
rip hunter time masters Timeship this
was that very same time ship so damian
darhk-- is riding inside season 1
reverse flashes Timeship but the other
big thing in the episode was explaining
what happened to the JSA so that happens
through obsidians character the
producers the actors have now all
confirmed that he is the son of the Alan
Scott Green Lantern just like in the
comics but as you see obsidian is an old
man here so the way Lance Henriksen
explained it the wait liked the way he
played the character is that he has a
lot of abandonment issues from his
father so something happened to Alan
Scott when he was a young boy he went we
know wait for it like most teenagers
went super dark when he was young but
now has kind of come back from that and
chilled out a little bit so he kind of
explains why there's no real JSA
basically everybody died on this mission
so that is why he is the only one who
was left alive so he just kind of left
with his grief like all of his friends
have died so the thing is is that you
know we only saw one JSA member in this
episode we're gonna jump around in time
we'll run into other members of the JSA
will see other JSA stuff in future
episodes so even though as of right now
they are basically gone like the JSA
doesn't exist anymore we will still see
more JSA stuff in the episodes and I
think part of the idea of the season in
them fixing things like them defeating
the reverse-flash and the Legion of Doom
is that they'll save everybody in the
past so that the JSA will go on to have
this really rich history and then
there'll be a more modern version of the
JSA in the future whether or not that
becomes the legends team but great
heatwave Ray's scenes I hate the 80s
you killed my beers do you want some
jelly beans yes yes I would like some
jelly beans and then when he's eating
the donut just as they're getting ready
to get blown to smithereens like well
you know oh well we're gonna die might
as well have a donut there were Star
Trek TNG shoutouts they even used Kenny
Loggins in the episode so Miami Vice Top
Gun reverse-flash probably one of my
favorite episodes but let me know in the
comments what would you guys favorite
moment from the episode and what do you
want them to do
with the Legion of Doom going forward
obviously they're gonna meet Malcolm
Merlyn eventually he'll join the team
then we'll see Captain Cold I know
everybody's wondering where Captain Cold
is he'll make his debut relatively
quickly it'll be interesting to see what
happens because Ray's been using his gun
so Captain Cold is probably going to be
pretty pissed about that but it's not
gonna be the same version of Captain
Cold
remember flashpoint the timelines been
changed so this version of captain codes
that we'll meet will be more evil he
will work with the Legion of Doom but if
you guys didn't see it the four night
crossover is coming up pretty quickly I
just posted the first trailer for that
so I'll put a link at the end of this
but it's only gonna get crazier from
here so I'll say congratulations to this
week's DC giveaway winner Juan Pereira
you win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details but what's gonna happen next is
they just dropped a whole bunch of Star
Wars rogue one footage so I'll do a
video for that be sure to subscribe to
get that there will be a new round of
the DC giveaway whenever I post my next
DC video so they'll be much more marvel
bunch more DC happening there's actually
a lot of stuff coming in December
especially comic book stuff but Rick and
Morty's Star Wars rogue one so you start
to see more videos for that stuff in the
next couple weeks - while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
the four night crossover trailer and you
can click here for a teaser for a killer
frost vibe comic book costumes thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight